du rap américain dans les rudes alep la
deuxième ville de syrie
un paradoxe quand on ne connaît pas le
pays ce n'est pas mon cas j'ai passé
toute mon adolescence à alep et comme
tout le monde ici j'ai appris à vivre en
permanence dans la contradiction
aujourd'hui c'est vendredi j'accompagne
une bande de copines au hammam de la
vieille ville c'est mon endroit préféré
à alep
la dernière fois que j'y suis allé
c'était il ya sept ans pour réaliser une
série de photos sur les vins et les
hammams du monde entier
je suis photographe syrienne par mon
père et tchèques par ma mère cela fait
un an que je ne suis pas revenu en syrie
[Musique]
l'entrée ne paye pas de mine mais le
hammam de la vieille ville est un des
rares à alep avoir été préservé en
l'état depuis que j'ai immortalisé son
établissement dans mon livre a book à
l'afp me fait confiance c'est pour ça
qu'il me laisse filmer
mais même avec moi il connaît les lignes
rouges à ne pas franchir
pendant qu'il m'explique où les femmes
rangent leurs petites affaires je
remarque par terre un portrait du
président défunt hafez al assad
ce parterre cette photo c'est la photo
de notre maître à tous
s'en remettre pour tous au président un
réflexe automatique en syrie c'est notre
guide est notre chef nous l'aimons du
fond du coeur
le moindre soupçon du contraire peut
vous conduire tout droit en prison
richemont comme chrétiennes ou
musulmanes
les femmes viennent de partout dans la
ville pour prendre un peu de bon temps
ici passer cette porte c'est la seule
réservé aux femmes seules hicham le fils
d'abou calaf a le droit de m'accompagner
pendant encore un an jusqu'à l'âge de 6
ans il pourra circuler librement au
milieu des femmes au bain de vapeur à
plus de 40 degrés dans la salle des
ablutions à l'eau glacée ou encore dans
la salle du gommage à lapierre d'alep un
secret de beauté jalouser depuis des
siècles par toutes les femmes de la
région
j'adore les paramédicaux
y voilà
direction la salle de repos où je
retrouve un joyeux brouhaha l'occasion
entre une bouffée de la revue les et
quelques gourmandises de se laisser
aller à toutes les audaces surtout quand
il s'agit de parler des hommes
10 mois qu'ils sont nuls de ta liberté
poser la question à ma voisine
non toi d'abord mois grâce à dieu je me
sens complètement libre la répression
c'est seulement la maison je la subis de
la part de mon mari
et vous au lycée les garçons ils vous
embête pas peut-être pas du tout au
lycée les garçons ne regarde pas du tout
les filles sinon leur couple et moi la
première je leur couple et tu parles
c'est au lycée que vous faites votre
éducation sexuelle ohlala mon dieu
qu'est ce que je raconte on va nous
prendre pour des dégénérés dieu nous
garde ne dit pas des choses pareilles on
va se faire tuer si on entend ça
[Applaudissements]
des plaisanteries grivoises de la danse
au rythme des derboukas pas de quoi
perturber ni même offusquer les plus
religieuses entre elles même quand c'est
l'heure de la prière
[Musique]
ces deux mondes qui se côtoient sans
jamais s'affronter ce fragile équilibre
entre religion et laïcité m'a toujours
séduit ta allait
mais en sortant du hammam alors que je
traverse le souffle pour me rendre dans
la ville nouvelle je suis malgré tout
surprise par le nombre de femmes voilées
des pieds à la tête que je rencontre sur
mon chemin une tenue imposée par les
islamistes les plus radicaux il semble
avoir gagné du terrain dans la vieille
ville depuis ma dernière visite
mais quelque chose d'autre a changé en
syrie et il suffit d'observer la
multitude d'antennes paraboliques
installés sur les toits d'alep pour
comprendre de quoi il s'agit
depuis six mois l'accès aux chaînes
satellitaires à internet et à la
téléphonie mobile a complètement
bouleversé les comportements
même un jour comme aujourd'hui l'ittihad
d'alep l'équipe locale de football son
titre de champion de syrie le premier
café internet de la ville ne désemplit
pas c'est là que j'ai rendez vous avec
nisreen et son petit frère samir
ordinateur dernier modèle accès à haut
débit et à ma grande surprise aucun
système de contrôle des sites visités
mesrine et samir surf comme n'importe
quel internaute de la planète samir tu
fais quoi là
ce sont les dernières nouveautés une
console de jeu qui vient de sortir
et tu viens souvent ici
oui donc je peux tu crées un seul ou
accompagné
mon nom soit les conduire depuis un
ordinateur chez toi oui
et toi nisrine
moi je chatte avec d'autres gens
inscrits non partout dans le monde et tu
parle de quoi avec des amis
on parle de la société de nos relations
de la vie quotidienne
comment on vit ici peut-être que je
trouverai quelqu'un comme ça
voilà regarde cela ils veulent tous me
rencontrer 17
17 nous resterons discret sur les
messages envoyés par les fiancés
potentiel de nisrine à l'étranger son
petit ami officiel à alep et jaloux
c'était qui mon petit copain il veut que
je le rejoigne tout de suite
et vous allez faire quoi on va
probablement aller au cinéma et en plus
d'être jaloux le petit ami de nisrine
est exclusif il a refusé que je les
accompagne cinéma ou pour quelques
heures de pénombre et de discrétion ils
vont comme beaucoup de jeunes couples
s'accommoder de la mauvaise qualité des
films projetés
c'est quoi le résultat
1-0
1-0 pour nous
alors tu es content samir oui c'est nous
qui avons gagné sa lettre à l'ex
champion de syrie on n'avait pas vu ça
depuis au moins deux décennies ce soir
la fête promet d'être énorme dans la
ville en attendant de retrouver nisrine
dans la soirée j'ai un peu de temps
devant moi quelques heures pendant
lesquelles je vais faire des rencontres
étonnantes d'abord au salon de coiffure
ont le tout allait bien se refaire une
beauté ici la nouvelle mode celle
épilation à l'irakienne avec un fil à
coudre à bagdad on s'en sert pour raser
les hommes au plus près redoutablement
efficace pour les poêles rebelles
[Musique]
le maître des lieux c'est louis georges
cale une star à alep mais aussi dans
tout le pays
[Musique]
ça c'est mon magazine préféré
c'est un magazine c'est rien qui paraît
tous les six mois
ce sont des modèles que j'ai créé avec
l'aide d'un ordinateur
c'est moi qui ai fait le maquillage et
la coiffure
[Musique]
vous êtes dans la mode depuis longtemps
cela fait douze ans à peu près
ici dans le salon depuis six ans
avant j'ai fait plusieurs stages à
beyrouth à paris à milan
mais c'est à alep que j'ai appris les
bases du métier
regardez là c'est un défilé qu'on a fait
à damas ces robes ont été imaginés par
ma fiancée c'est elle qui les a dessinés
et qui les a réalisés
allez syrienne oui elle est syrienne
mais elle a fait ses études dans une
école française esmod tous ces profs
étaient français toutes les robes que
vous voyez sont des créations originales
george joffe date call le coiffeur et sa
fiancée créatrice de mode ont déjà deux
défilés à leur actif à damas le rêve
présenter leurs modèles à paris
[Musique]
il est 20 heures les rues de la ville
appartiennent aux supporters de
l'ittihad l'équipe de football d'alep en
les suivant je découvre par hasard le
nouveau lieu de rendez-vous des ados le
batata littéralement la pomme de terre
un fast food qui est une copie exacte de
l'enseignent américaine mcdonald's
rigoureusement interdite en syrie en
l'espace de quelques minutes j'ai
l'impression de me retrouver dans la
fureur de vivre médina les foulards aux
couleurs du drapeau américain
tatouage au bras et maillot de basket de
la nba
[Applaudissements]
tu travaille depuis longtemps si ça fait
depuis un an
depuis l'ouverture
et depuis pour tous ceux qui en syrie
ont juré la perte de l'impérialisme
américain la concurrence est rude
vous êtes directeur oui désolé de vous
recevoir dans cette tenue la directeur
du bata il a 27 ans et pour le marketing
il n'a de leçon à recevoir de personne
l'idée c'était de faire comme mcdonald's
oui bien sûr
on utilise les mêmes frites
on utilise aussi la même huile à frire
c'est de l'huile végétale
[Musique]
demain et le fin pour les burgers dont
l'un porte d'arabie séoudite c'est le
même qui les utilisent pour mcdonald's
là bas
[Musique]
il y a que la viande qui est syrienne
series on pense que la viande si ayem
est la meilleure viande au monde
elle poids sens
je crois que oui c'est le même que celui
qu'utilise mcdonald's
c'est un peu embarrassant mais je crois
bien qu'on fait tout comme eux
de livres 50 soit un euro et demi le
hamburger à raison de vingt mille vendu
à la semaine une affaire en or pour les
jeunes businessman
à quelques centaines de mètres du bata
le rendez-vous des ados d'alep la rose
café le fief des trentenaires
c'est là que je dois retrouver nisrine
et ses amis elles font toutes partie de
la jeunesse dorée d'alep chose rare en
syrie la plupart n'a pas besoin de
travailler pour vivre comme nesrine
elles sont toutes célibataires
on se retrouve dès la sortie des cours
le week-end
et aujourd'hui c'est une occasion
spéciale la fin de l'année oui c'était
la fin des cours et le début de l'été
et comme les screen elle rêve tout du
prince charmant
zinn elle s'est fait refaire le nez pour
plaire à son petit ami soixante quinze
mille livres syriennes l'opération soit
1200 euros une fortune pour le pays pas
pour elle c'est un bon docteur tout à
opérer oui c'est un bon docteur j'aime
ce qu'il a fait parce que ça a l'air
naturel ça n'a pas l'air fou oui il a
vraiment l'air naturel
oui c'est vrai
tu aimes les garçons oui j'aime vraiment
les garçons mais le problème c'est qu'il
n'est même pas
toutes façons il n'y a pas d'homme à
marier ici
difficile de trouver chaussure à son
pied en syrie surtout quand tomlin
unissent rinne on n'a pas tous les
canons de beauté requis telle opération
je dois encore faire à votre avis rien
du tout vraiment rien
pourquoi vous pensez le contraire
donc je crois qu'il faut
ouais fern faire moi ça même entre
copines il faut savoir garder une
certaine pudeur
le lendemain à deux pas de la citadelle
d'alep j'ai rendez vous avec south and à
la chrétienne
elle habite dans un des quartiers les
plus modestes de la ville
c'est le coeur historique d'alep mais la
plupart de ces maisons sont laissés à
l'abandon une aubaine pour south est né
son mari qui peuvent se loger
confortablement dans un trois pièces
ici pas d'internet ni même d'ordinateur
demain je rentrerai tard du travail mais
toi fais tes devoirs pendant ce temps là
et si tu as des questions note le sur un
papier et je t'aiderai après
sa hausse en a trois enfants avec son
mari ils ont fait 5 ans d'études pour
devenir ingénieur ils travaillent tous
les deux dans une entreprise d'état avec
leurs deux salaires ils atteignent tout
juste les 160 euros par mois à
l'étranger ils pourraient être payés dix
fois plus
voilà ce que nous importons de
l'occident
ne voyez pas des coiffures comme
celle-là vend maintenant on envoie tout
est
comme ça avec une crête
ça au sol et son mari ne peuvent compter
que sur eux mêmes ils n'ont pas de
famille alerte alors depuis que la
dernière est née sa hausse à n'a plus
une minute à elle il faudrait que les
journées durent trente six heures pour
pouvoir faire tout ce que j'ai à faire
mais je ne peux pas laisser tomber mon
travail on a trop besoin de mon salaire
ou les classes moyennes nous sommes en
train de nous appauvrir
les livres coûtent cher l'instruction
coûte cher le cinéma le théâtre au coût
de chasse
voilà le problème des gens qui ont fait
des études supérieures ou régresse c'est
dur
c'est trop dur économiquement
aujourd'hui il ya de plus en plus de
gens qui veulent partir que toi tu veux
partir quand tu auras fini tes études
pourquoi je me dis que quoi que je fasse
ici je ne m'en sortirais pas quand je
vois la situation les parents je me dis
que je dois faire mieux avoir une belle
voiture une belle maison voyager ici je
n'aurais pas les mêmes opportunités qu'à
l'étranger quelles études veux tu faire
quand tu seras grande
aux médecins ou décoratrice
ce soir là je vais assister ma première
manifestation en syrie
une cinquantaine de jeunes rassemblés
place de la poste sur les banderoles ils
demandent purement et simplement d'être
libéré de l'armée après leurs trois ans
de service militaire obligatoire
[Applaudissements]
alors
dino
les membres des moukhabarat les
redoutables services de renseignement
syriens sont presque plus nombreux que
sur la place de la poste
je vais moi même être interrogé et
conduite par la sécurité le soir lorsque
je m'aperçois que journal télévisé n'est
fait aucune mention de la manifestation
je décide de me rendre au siège de la
télévision d'état pour en savoir plus
pour cela il me faut prendre le train
direction damas avant il était
totalement interdit de filmer dans une
gare aujourd'hui les inévitables agents
de renseignements me regarde ta peine
quand je sors ma caméra pareil à
l'intérieur du wagon
s'est défendu de filmer dans le wagon
parce qu'il me faut une autorisation
signée
québec j'ai des problèmes quelques mots
suffiront pour que le contrôleur
détourne son regard
depuis mon arrivée des rumeurs sur la
fin du parti unique sur l'organisation
d'élections libres ou sur la libération
de tous les prisonniers politiques vont
bon train dans le pays et notamment dans
les cercles bien informés à damas mais
ce ne sont que des rumeurs et comme va
me le dire le chauffeur de taxi qui
m'emmène à la télévision ici on a appris
à voir avant de croire
il paraît qu'il va y avoir des réformes
c'est ce qu'ils disent en tout cas
mais je vais vous dire une chose le
président n'a pas une baguette magique
il ne peut pas tout changer du jour au
lendemain
la télévision d'état syrienne est au
coeur de la machine de propagande du
régime depuis quelques mois c'est une
femme qui en est la présidente et elle
n'appartient pas au parti baas le parti
unique en syrie je ne pourrais pas la
rencontrer exceptionnellement je suis
autorisé à parler avec la présentatrice
de l'édition en langue anglaise du
journal
je vais vous montrer la salle des
échanges internationaux auxquels j'ai
besoin bien sûr
la c reuters
la société secrète et là les agences de
presse arabes et genesis
ça c'est une blessure à israël
ah non ici on doit dire palestine un
territoire occupé ou cisjordanie c'est
plus facile de travailler aujourd'hui
que quand vous êtes arrivé il ya cinq
ans
ça c'est une question embarrassante
c'est un peu le sens de ma question êtes
vous plus libre qu'avant on commence à
changer peu à peu
tu parle arabe elle parlera ben oui
mais j'espère que les choses vont aller
plus loin
j'espère que nous pourrons aller plus
loin a dit que vous pensez que c'est
possible
je pense qu'il faut que ça aille plus
loin
comme la présentatrice du journal
télévisé
aujourd'hui ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à oser s'exprimer ouvertement à
tester les limites de ce qu'on peut dire
ou ne pas dire dans le pays
retour à alep où je retrouve le docteur
nabil kabbani un désole-t-elle mot
logist les plus réputés du pays il est
rentré en syrie il ya tout juste un an
après des études et une carrière
brillante aux états unis
c'est quoi ce cadre
c'est un article de journal du temps
j'habitais là l'été 1989
il faut les mettre au mur
j'en ai encore tellement dans les
caisses regardez là mes diplômes de la
faculté de géorgie
c'est toute l'histoire de ma vie dans
ses caisses
ce qu'il ya de formidable en amérique
c'est qu'on vous donne une chance dans
la vie j'ai quitté la syrie et l'âge de
18 ans je venais de finir le lycée
j'avais un billet d'avion 200 $ dans mes
poches et c'est tout
ça ce sont des machines américaines
cela a été dur de les amener ici très
dur
il a fallu qu'on les envoie d'abord à
dubaï dans la zone franche de jebel ali
et là on a changé les papiers et puis
elles ont été envoyées à damas on ne
peut rien faire venir des états unis
directement non
pourquoi
parce que les états unis interdisent
l'importation de tous ses produits en
syrie mais qu'est ce que mes machines
ont à voir avec tout ça
elles servent seulement à aider les gens
c'est honteux un embargo parce que la
syrie reste sur la liste des pays
terroristes établie par le pentagone
mais cela n'a pas arrêté le docteur
kabbani il a cru en la capacité du
président bachar al assad de changer les
choses il a très vite déchanté
et on a dû payer 170 livres syriennes
3000 euros qui sont allés directement
dans la poche des employés du
gouvernement local
de la municipalité
oui juste pour qu'on puisse terminer les
travaux tranquillement
tout part dans la poche des officiels
et tout ça pour qu'il regarde dans une
autre direction
le docteur kabbani a investi plus d'un
million d'euros pour construire sa
clinique mais aujourd'hui il a épuisé
tous les recours parce qu'un jour il a
refusé de payer un pot-de-vin à un
employé de la municipalité il ne sait
toujours pas quand il pourra enfin
ouvrir son établissement il ya beaucoup
de choses ici qui ne vont pas mais ce
n'est pas le peuple syrien le problème
ce sont ses 40 ans de pouvoir écrasant
le problème
étudié vient les gens ici la manière
dont ils vivent
vous vous rendez compte qu'ils sont
humbles ils sont respectueux des
traditions
début c'est vrai ils ont l'air un peu
dur mais au fond les syriens sont
formidables
c'est un grand peuple avec une grande
culture une grande histoire
économie de marché société de
consommation pour le meilleur et pour le
pire le rav occidentale est devenue
accessible pour les syriens depuis
quelques mois mais cela suffira-t-il à
balayer 40 ans de dirigisme et de
dictature après trois semaines passées
sur place je m'inquiète surtout de la
brutalité et donc de la fragilité de ce
changement peut-être ne s'agira-t-il
encore une fois que d'un mirage comme il
ya quatre ans lors de ce fameux
printemps de damas après la mort du
président hafez al assad quelques mois
de liberté s'était terminée par une
terrible répression